When you're working with materials
coming from Stephen King's mind,
it's a huge challenge.
It was a very long process of
investigation, designing, discovering,
because it has to be beautiful,
it has to be mysterious.
We wanted to create a world
that we have not seen before.
Design in feature films and television
is a very lengthy process
of back and forth with
the Director and the creator.
It's an epic undertaking.
Pablo and Stephen King
wanted this to feel stylized.
Everything looks real,
everything looks unreal,
-at the same time.
-Yeah.
So much of this is experimental.
We just had to kind of design as we went.
I read the novel first, and then,
obviously, I read your script treatment.
And it was interesting to see
your interpretation
from the novel to the script
and the details that you wanted
to keep in the script,
and the stuff that you didn't.
One of the things that I did was
I thought to myself,
"This is a place where it's always twilight,
it's always kind of a mystery.
This is a place
that's outside of time, kind of."
And that's the way that you built it.
Mystery is not only in how it looks.
It can also be in the way that it's shot.
When Pablo talked to me
about Boo'ya Moon, it was difficult.
When you read Boo'ya Moon,
if you don't know anything,
how would you do Boo'ya Moon?
So the concept was born between
Pablo, and then Guy, and then me.
And then we just all
had this interpretation,
and then Boo'ya Moon became
Pablo's Boo'ya Moon.
Darius really knows how to create
suspense with his images,
how to create
things that can be unsettling.
I'll take you there again.
Yeah.
When you read it, you think,
"How are they going to create this world?"
It's literally complete epic otherworldly.
Pablo Larraín is a tremendous director.
Darius Khondji is one of the
best cinematographers in the world.
It's so, so beautiful.
It's a fantastic opportunity
to recreate what you imagine
Stephen King had in mind when
he was writing this extraordinary story.
It was so beautifully rendered, this world.
I can't say enough about
the entire production.
It's a narrative that comes from
Stephen King's world
that was embraced by
all these incredible artists and producers.
And I hope the audience will
connect with it
in the most beautiful way.